you need a multi-pronged approach when  it comes to  trans youth people under 18.  there are medical aspects to this there  are social aspects to this there are  educational aspects to this there are  mental health aspects to this there are  policy related questions that have to be  answered  I don't pretend to have all the answers  and I believe that a lot of the specific  elements of this are still being studied  what I can tell you for sure is that  we're not going to get to the best  outcome for the trans youth by allowing  Republicans to set the terms of the  debate  to ban all sorts of things again as if  they know better than doctors which were  familiar with them when it comes to  abortion and on and on and on